What a world...Universe now.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new Marvel Avengers video
for Marvel phase four in some of the new
movies that are coming up a lot of new
sites are reporting that Marvel has very
special plans for ant-man 3 so this
would be a breakdown of the new Avengers
team and what's going on with ant-man 3
I do Marvel videos every week if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get everything we're also doing a
Disney Plus giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your favorite ant-man moment on the
video so we'll just go down the list
here starting with the ant-man 3 stuff
and how this sets up New Avengers
because it ties together a lot of
theories about what's going on with
Marvel the Disney Plus series in the big
movie step during Marvel phase 4 it's
starting to make a little more sense now
starting with number 5 the new rider
that Marvel just hired for ant-man 3 why
do they hire someone from Rick & Morty
to do ant-man 3 what does that mean if
you've been following all the new Marvel
stuff since they dropped the Marvel
phase 4 trailer they're actually a bunch
of other Rick and Morty riders that are
working on Marvel movies and Marvel TV
shows right now so Marvel has a long
history of borrowing Rick and Morty
riders to do their big projects the
showrunner of she-hulk is Jessica Gow
she was the writer of pickle Rick Rick
and Morty season 3 episode 3 she won an
Emmy Award for that Marvel hired another
Rick and Morty writer to do the Loki's
series which is in the middle of filming
when the virus started delaying
everything they're still about half way
done with Loki right now then Dan Harmon
himself was actually hired to rework
some of the multiverse parts of the
first Doctor Strange movie I think that
had a little bit to do with the Dormammu
plot so there's a lot of Rick and
Morty's synergy with the MCU right now
the reason that Marvel gave a long time
ago for going after Rick and Morty
people was that Rick and Morty as a show
does a really good job of explaining
very complex ideas and science in very
simple ways and because Marvel phase
four is all about the multiverse
according to Kevin Feige that starts to
get very complex for people who don't
follow every single Marvel movie and
aren't really up on the science of how
the multiverse works so as crazy as
things got during ant-man and the wasp
with the quantum realm and quantum
energy and the way the ghosts phased
through different dimensions it sounds
like ant-man 3 will be even crazier
number 4 we found out that Paul Rudd
she submitted a scrip for ant-man three
that was the introduction of MODOK
through aim he was meant to be the big
villain remember aim from Iron Man three
advanced idea mechanics that's the
comic-book organization that in the
movies Aldrich Killian was behind and he
was the fake version of the Mandarin
behind this fake version of the Mandarin
Trevor that they're now going to pick up
with during shang-chi in the legend of
the ten rings the new sights are
reporting that Marvel decided not to go
with Paul Rudd's script one because he
wrote it before Avengers infinity war
and Avengers in game on his own and Paul
Rudd wasn't given a full script for
either infinity war or endgame so his
version of the script didn't take into
account anything that happened during
those two Avengers movies like any the
really big stuff like Iron Man dying the
Infinity Gauntlet snaps and now teenage
version of Cassie Lang played by Emma
Furman he didn't know about that going
into Avengers end game so it wasn't in
his version of ant-man 3 even though
they hired this new Rick and Morty
writer to do a new version of the script
I don't know if they're keeping MODOK in
ant-man 3 if he's going to be a character
or they're going to pick some other villain
but you can see the logic and doing a
character as ridiculous as MODOK in the
ant-man movies because they're typically
more comedic movies they're actually
doing an adult animation MODOK TV show
for Hulu Patton Oswalt is going to be the
voice of MODOK which seems very
appropriate the actor John Hodgman has
also been a friend of director Peyton
Reed and has been campaigning to play
MODOK in the Marvel movies since 2015 no
joke so maybe that was part of the
inspiration for including MODOK in the
original version of ant-man 3 but number
3 most of the news reports say that
they've actually swapped out MODOK in
this big aim arc during that movie in
favor of get it a young Avengers
storyline no one knows if that means
they're doing full-blown young Avengers
team-up
or if it's going to be cameos because we
don't even have a full young Avengers
comic book squad yet we have teenage
Cassie Lang's stature who in a couple
years will be full-blown adult Cassie
Lang especially if Ant Man 3 isn't
released until 2022 or 2023 they were
always kind of implying I think that
eventually she would become the stature
character even if they didn't always
have really big Young Avengers plans
inside the ant-man movies there were
some deleted scenes from ant-man and the
wasps that depicted all the extra things
that Scott Lang did with young Cassie
he was still under house arrest in one
of them included shrinking Cassie down
with the old ant-man suit from the first
movie in writing the ants around for fun
so it seems like they were oh is teasing
Cassie Lang stature but they weren't
always sure what they were going to do with
the five-year time jump in adult Cassie
Lang that seems like something the
Russos did themselves number two so
naturally we can assume Emma Furman is
going to come back and play the older
version of Cassie and they'll build her
a suit at some point during the movie
and if they really are doing young
Avengers as the news reports are saying
and some crossover cameos from the other
young Avengers comic book characters
they're probably going to be the ones that
debut during the Marvel phase four
projects that we've learned about so far
even though a lot of filming on those
are delayed right now and they haven't
cast all those characters we know about
Kate Bishop Hawkeye from the Hawkeye
series we know about she-hulk we know
about Miss Marvel Kamala Khan impossible
scarlet witch's children Wiccan and
speed featured in the Wanda vision
trailer the only of the really young
characters in the MCU right now that are
on par with the ages of The Young
Avengers characters they're setting up
in the Disney Plus series are obviously
Tom Hollands spider-man and then you
have Cherie she's the exact same age as
Tom Hollands spider-man remember though
the reason for hiring this Rick and
Morty person to oversee this crazy
multiverse story arc is because we're
doing a bigger multiverse narrative arc
across Marvel phase four think of it as
the multiverse saga like you do the
infinity saga based on the Infinity
stones the Infinity Gauntlet now we're
getting into the multiverse multiple
dimensions mutants and a lot more crazy
magic the news reports that are talking
about Young Avengers don't say who the
villain of this version of the movie
would be if they're not going to do MODOK
or if they'll try someone like King the
Conqueror because he's a big Young
Avengers villain in reportedly he's
going to be teased somehow during the
Loki Disney Plus series because it's
going to be a time travel based series if
we don't know that the whole movie is
going to be dedicated to establishing
the Young Avengers or if it's just going to
be a brief cameo at the end of the movie
Michael Douglas has been leaking all
kinds of details about what's going on
with the movie when they're going to start
filming and some details about the story
he did say after ant-man of the wasps
that they would continue to explore the
quantum realm and quantum energy so
whatever they're doing with young
Avengers and with the other villains
it's going to involve that my assumption
in the Modoc version of the script is
what they would have done is
they would have turned MODOK into that
mysterious benefactor in aim that sunny
birch was working for with billions of
dollars to blow that wanted to get their
hands on Hank Pimm's lab and all that
quantum energy since it sounds like
MODOK is not in the movie anymore those
Easter eggs are still in play you're
still free to theory craft about what
that means there were even some deleted
scenes during ant-man and the wasp with
them down in the quantum realm and Janet
Van Dyne trying to explain the quantum
city and all the living organisms down
there they'll pick up on during ant-man
3.
There's so much we didn't know about
this place Henry. Worlds upon worlds. Entire civilizations
far more than we ever theorized.
It's ok.
Passing through. We stake no claim.
Go in peace.
There.
When I thought I was gone but that
energy from your hands how did you do that?
I'm not the same woman I was 30
years ago Henry this place it changes
you I mean adaptation is part of it but
some of it is evolution
Remember that Janet Van Dyne was also
altered by the quantum energy now she
has mutant like abilities they'll
probably play a part in the story in a
larger goal of establishing mutants in
the MCU through a bunch of different
ways in the past typically we talked
about mutants as people who had the X
gene from the x-men comics but Kevin
Feige said that he thinks of it as a
broader term so that also includes
characters like the Fantastic Four who
technically aren't mutants they're
called mutates so it's a really subtle
distinction but I think that the MCU
movies will just have a really simple
way of explaining mutants in number one
that infamous video of Luis recapping
the MCU the entire 10 year history you
may have seen a janky version of this at
some point from the past but back at
Comic Con 2017 when Marvel screened the
first footage of Avengers infinity war
in Hall H they also screened a special
clip from ant-man the wasp of Scott Lang
and Lewis recapping the entire 10 year
history of the MCU to Janet Van Dyne
Marvel never posted the epic Lewis recap
video online but Kevin Feige and
director Peyton Reed said that they
would at some point early theory they're
saving that for ant-man 3 is a way to
recap everything and catch ever went up
since endgame because so much stuff has
happened recently if you do happen to
have an HD version of that feel free to
message me because I have not been able
to find one Marvel keeps taking them
down every time someone posted but
everyone post all your Young Avengers
theories in the comments if they show up
during ant-man 3 do you think it's going to
be a small cameo or do you think the
whole movie is going to be about setting up
the Young Avengers team my assumption is
is they debut during that movie then
they would do that is a Disney Plus
series but I guess it's always possible
they could do a full-blown Young
Avengers MCU movie it just depends on
how big they want to go with it you want
to get people excited about an ant-man
movie you put the Young Avengers and you
put kanga
in that movie congratulations Steven B
zero five zero three-year the giveaway
winner from my last big marble video
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your details every
one click here to learn about all the
major Marvel phase four movie changes
they just announced and click here for
my new avengers Wolverine Weapon X video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe. I'll see you guys tonight!